entre nous vous et moi qui ne sommes pas
pris dans les bouchons
nous allons pouvoir par les vacances ce
que je vous propose maintenant c'est de
rêver un peu en partant pour la
yougoslavie dans la région très belle du
monténégro sur la côte adriatique
récompense du long voyage entre myr
découvrir sveti stefan ancien village de
pêcheurs luxueusement restaurer à
l'intention de ceux que l'on moyens
permet d'y loger parmi des lauriers les
pins décidiez aux odeurs enivrantes sous
le soleil
ils ont tous
l'armada non
i
une autre
4 mai
pour qui
oui
g
gagné
mon refus
les plages du monténégro étroite bande
de sable étirés en longueur
coincée entre la montagne et la mer
budva a gagné la médaille d'argent au
concours des plus belles plages d'europe
c'était au concours international de
paris en 1930
et les plages populaire rassemblement de
roulottes de tentes de familles de
travailleurs en majorité yougoslave
jours
bon là
mon mari et mon bougeant bataillon
oh
au coeur des montagnes près de lac
sauvage la ville qui fut la capitale du
monténégro jusqu'en 1946 settini louis
capitale royale
lorsque le monténégro était indépendant
avant 1914 la preuve voici l'ancienne
ambassade de france aujourd'hui
bibliothèque municipale les retraités et
il sait les kayaks et il sera père de la
patrie
les joueurs de gloire est arrivé contre
nous de la tyrannie
l'étendard sanglant m notre ben henda
hendoud vis des blacks